in the many years since home alone's
release in 1990 it's become evident that
while kevin mcallister's solo yuletide
adventures are still tremendously fun to
watch
there are a lot of things about this
film that are a little too bizarre
illogical or even downright disturbing
if you're a kid watching home alone
kevin's dialogue feels almost
aspirational
the things he says to his parents and
other family members are the kinds of
things we all wished we could say when
we were young but probably never have
the nerve to do so
when his mom tells him to leave her room
for example he responds
hang up the phone and make me why don't
you and then when she tells him to go
upstairs after he shoves his brother
buzz in the kitchen he shouts back
upstairs i am upstairs dummy granted
kevin is in the midst of being punished
when he says this but still calling your
mom a dummy
and suffering zero consequences would
have felt like a dream for young
moviegoers
however as an adult it's a little hard
to overlook just how rude kevin is and
how his parents either ignore it or
laugh it off
to be fair most of the other mcallister
kids are just as bad if not worse
so kevin really doesn't stand out that
much in comparison making the idea of
traveling to paris with so many
disrespectful kids sound more like a
nightmare than a vacation
still considering that kevin is the
protagonist it's a little weird that
he's characterized as being just as
unpleasant to be around as the rest of
the kids and his family
even if you put aside the fact that the
mcallisters have clearly spent a small
fortune decorating every inch of their
expensive home for a holiday they're not
even going to be home for
have you ever taken a close look at the
rest of that house it's not just the
seasonal decorations that make it feel
festive
the entire interior design scheme seems
to have been planned around the holiday
just consider the green kitchen counters
and red pots and pans or the red green
and white patterned wallpaper covering
the walls of nearly every room and
hallway
and there's also the parents red bed
spread the framed red flowers on their
walls and the red and green furniture in
the living room the kitchen floor is red
the dining room walls are red the
upstairs walls are green the living room
has a red and white rug on the floor and
green curtains framing the windows
even the telephone is green from
lampshades to bathrobes to prominently
place teapots it's hard to find a single
surface or person in the mcallister
house that isn't decked out for the
holidays all the time
after living in such a festive home year
round it's no wonder the mcallister
children seem to be fresh out of
christmas cheer by the time december
arrives
when kevin shoves buzz for saying he ate
kevin's entire cheese pizza
buzz falls into some cups of milk which
spill all over the passports and airline
tickets on the kitchen counter
the next morning during the hubbub to
get everyone out of the house into the
airport on time
kevin's dad peter mentions that the
passports are in the microwave where he
put them in order to dry them off
this microwave plan was probably a bad
idea for several reasons
although passports in 1990 wouldn't have
had the radio frequency identification
chips contained in modern passports
which would have caused them to burst
into flames in the microwave they still
would have had plastic covers which
would have melted the passports also
would have contained small amounts of
metal and the foil stamping on their
covers in the inner security features
which would have caused them to catch
fire
peter's lucky he didn't cause the whole
trip to go up in flames
although at least in that case kevin
wouldn't have accidentally been left at
home by himself
kevin's mom kate realizes on the plane
that she left kevin behind and the first
thing she does after landing is wrestle
a payphone away from a french woman so
she can call the police
what follows is a frustrating series of
conversations as kate gets transferred
from one department to another and
conveys her story over and over to board
officers who seem more interested in
preparing for christmas than in
ensuring a child's safety if you're a
kid watching the scene it's easy to get
annoyed at the police
especially at the officer who later goes
to the mcallister house knocks once
and gives up and leaves when no one
answers the door surely this police
department is the height of professional
incompetence right
as it turns out though maybe not when
kate calls all she says each time
is yeah hi look i'm calling from paris i
have a son who's home alone our phones
are out of order so i'd like somebody to
go over to our house
tell them that we're coming home to get
him she never mentions kevin's age or
the fact that he's not supposed to be
alone
instead she comes across as an
overprotective parent who purposely left
her teenager at home and now wants the
police to make sure he isn't throwing a
rager while she's away
no wonder the police didn't bother
investigating further when kevin didn't
answer the door
it can seem illogical that kevin never
calls the police until the end of the
movie choosing instead to construct an
elaborate series of booby traps to
protect himself
but by kevin's logic it actually makes
sense he thinks he made his family
disappear by magic and when he later
encounters the wet bandits he recognizes
harry as the police officer who visited
his house earlier
police can't help with a magically
disappearing family and they may in fact
be the bad guys if harry is one of them
but it's less clear why the pizza guy
doesn't call 9-1-1 after he delivers a
pie to the mcallister home and kevin
uses the angels with filthy souls video
to trick him into believing someone is
trying to kill him
the ruse clearly works but then nothing
happens
if he's under the impression that one of
his customers just tried to kill him
you'd think he'd call the police or at
least report it to his manager who could
pass the incident along to the
authorities
but it appears that instead he just
keeps it to himself and goes about the
rest of his day
during the break-in extravaganza at the
end of the film kevin knows to be ready
because the web bandits inadvertently
tell him to expect them at nine o'clock
but when he sets up his elaborate fake
party all he knows is that two creepy
guys in a van were hanging around
outside his house earlier in the day
he had no way of knowing what time
they'd be coming back or if they were
even planning on returning at all
yet somehow he managed to be
enthusiastically dancing at the precise
moment when harry and marv drove by that
night
either kevin was incredibly lucky with
his timing or he'd already been partying
for hours with his cardboard friends by
the time the wet bandits finally
returned
the most plausible explanation is that
he had the whole party set up ready to
go as soon as their van turned onto a
street
kept a close watch and it was a lot less
complicated than it appeared for him to
put all the cutouts in motion
but it's more fun to imagine that he was
just rocking out with his inanimate
guests all day
although the church scene between kevin
and old man marley is heartwarming it's
hard not to notice that it's also a
little odd while watching it as an adult
even if you put aside the fact that
kevin is in a church an hour before the
wet bandits are due to arrive and he has
to run home in order
to make his battle plan work in time
there are still a few elements about the
scene that are kind of strange when you
examine them closely
it makes sense that old man marley would
come over to introduce himself to kevin
and tell him that he doesn't need to be
afraid of him
after all it would have been hard for
him to miss his young neighbor fleeing
from him in terror earlier in the movie
however it's a little bizarre that
marley then proceeds to unload all of
his troubles with his estranged son onto
a second grader he's only just met
and whose parents are nowhere in sight
of course we understand that marley
means well
especially when it comes to kevin's
rescue at the end of the film but
typically adults don't have impromptu
heart to hearts with unaccompanied
minors they don't know
of the many traps kevin sets for the wet
bandits one that could have proved
disastrous is the electric charcoal
starter that he hangs from the front
doorknob
the idea behind it is simple even if the
physics are a little advanced for a
second grader
kevin plugs in the starter inside the
house hangs it on the indoor metal knob
which conducts the heat to the outdoor
knob and ultimately sears an impression
of itself onto an unsuspecting harry's
hand
after harry gives up on the front
entrance kevin leaves the starter
plugged in and hanging on the door
keeping in mind that it had already been
on the door for about an hour before
harry showed up
that starter was probably left
unattended for at least a couple of
hours before kevin turned it off
in that time there would have been a
serious risk of the door and
subsequently the entire house catching
fire
it's pretty cool as you can burn the
place down the traps that kevin sets for
the wet bandits at the end of the movie
all seem like delightfully funny pranks
when you're a kid
but as an adult it's easy to see the
many ways that could have resulted in
death
both criminals take some serious blows
to their heads and the rest of their
bodies during the home invasion sequence
any one of which could have proved
lethal first there's the iron dropped on
marv's face via the laundry chute
which falls three stories to hit him
squarely in the forehead that's enough
for severe facial trauma and bone
fractures
then there are the paint cans both
bandits take to the face which could
have taken their heads right off
and let's not forget the crowbar that
marv used to whack harry in the chest
which could have broken his ribs
punctured his lungs or pierced his heart
and that's not even taking into account
all the other injuries both men likely
suffered as a result of kevin's less
lethal traps
somehow we doubt that the mcallister's
vcrs and jewelry were worth all of that
you guys give up or you're thirsty for
more
while it's understandable why the police
don't seem to take kevin's plight too
seriously earlier in the movie it's a
little less easy to follow their process
at the end
after receiving kevin's call that the
murphy's house is being robbed the
police arrive
to discover harry and marv significantly
worse for wear presumably still being
watched over by old man marley in his
shovel
harry and marv are arrested and kevin
watches from the window of his house
where he then goes to bed and peacefully
awaits christmas morning
why don't the police ever question kevin
they must have wondered why the wet
bandits were so beaten up and in such a
weird way
what with the feathers and burn wounds
on harry and the iron-shaped impression
on marb's face
even if marley attempted to take
responsibility for it the bandits were
fully conscious when the police showed
up
and they would likely have been
grumbling about the kid that did this to
them it's bizarre that no one ever comes
to get kevin's side of the story and in
the process realize that he's home by
himself
if the police were better at their jobs
kevin's mom probably would have arrived
home to an empty house
and the message that her son was at the
police station sure it would have taken
away from the moving family reunion at
the end but it would have helped with
everyone's peace of mind
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one